while our state's water dilemmas haven't
dried out just yet in fact to respond
the Southern Nevada Water Authority
could be receiving even more Authority
that's to limit water use if this
assembly bill is past this legislative
session Ryan Matthew joining us live
from The Newsroom with the potential
here Ryan yeah David Denise currently
other lawmakers need to approve any cuts
to how much water you're allowed to use
but ab220 if passed could make Nevada
one of the only states to give that
sweeping power to its water authority
and this comes as Lake Mead continues to
see record low levels almost all of our
water comes from there actually this
bill would allow the water authority to
limit residential water usage during a
declared shortage and we've been under a
federally declared shortage since 2021.
the limit would be just slightly more
than what the average household uses at
about 160 000 gallons a year but some of
the largest offenders here use over 70
times that
in the big picture ab220
wants to get seeks to give the the water
authority and our local governments the
flexibility they need to respond quickly
if the situation on in the Colorado
River system declines now the bill would
also prohibit the use of Colorado River
water on non-functional Turf there are a
few exceptions to that though businesses
would also need to get permission if
they want to put grass on their property
and today was just the first hearing on
this item and it could be a long road
ahead before any action is actually
taken on this David Ryan thank you and
the bill goes even further to require
many homes using Wells to connect to the
sewer system in 30 years if you're
keeping track that is in 2054.